Hello world at Saroj.
Let's go through three dots.
You have to see the first example is
an Israeli startup called the zoos.
Zoos Zuzu,
the decentralized version of Uber.
Uber is a centralized right sharing it.
That means all data requests and decisions
go through a central server owned by
Uber.
Uber decides how much drivers get paid
and can see where your writing is going
whenever they want to.
Let's do this decentralized because it's
owned by the community instead of a few
people who own a giant server,
the APP uses its own internal
currency called Zeus Tokens.
These tokens are
cryptocurrency like Bitcoin,
except there are no minors maintaining
the network with computing power,
so no proof of work algorithm.
Instead,
the miners are drivers who maintain a
network with the amount of miles they
driven. They get rewarded with zoos
tokens based on how much they drive.
It's an algorithm called
proof of movement.
Writers pay the drivers with
the same tokens for rods.
So how does everyone get tokens?
Will Zeus has something
called the crowdsale a crowd
sale and adapt this kind of
like an IPO on day one.
The creators of the DAP decide how many
tokens they want to create and then sell
them at some initially decided price.
These tokens act as both currency
in the APP as well as equity.
Since you are an early adopter,
you should be rewarded for being
one of the first to use the deck.
The more valuable that that becomes,
the more valuable the tokens becomes.
So you can trade tokens for Fiat currency
to spend on other things if you'd like.
Since the APP is peer to peer,
that means data moves from phone to
phone with no server intermediary and the
APP is open source.
So if you want to develop for it or set
up a team of developers and contribute,
you can do that.
You can post it proposal for how
much you'd like to get paid as well.
Same for designers or marketers. The
community decides on fund to allocation.
There are different ways to reach
consensus and these are being experimented
with currently,
but overall it's a more democratic system
where the people who use the APP get
to participate in how
the APP itself is run.
The founders created a legal corporation
and the bylaws require that the obey
the will of the community's books so it
looks like it's already off to a good
start.
The second example is called open bazaar.
Open bazaar is a decentralized Ebay.
Ebay decide what you can.
Account cell takes a half d cut of all
transactions and you have to be in a
country that allows Ebay to use bit.
Openbazaar has a platform that lets buyers
and sellers connects directly to the
seller of goods without involving with
third party to hope to data and charge a
transaction fee.
The craters really wanted to build on
the idea of creating a truly free trade
platform.
I mean,
they're never really has been anything
like the bizarre is the pass on the
Internet.
Bizarre is where peer to peer marketplaces
where buyers and sellers could
interact directly with one another
without any middlemen in between gable to
observe the transaction.
Openbazaar doesn't have its own token,
but it doesn't use bitcoin for payments.
They've got some dope algorithms to solve
some interesting problems. For example,
when it comes to the issue of identity,
they use an algorithm called proof of
burn to ensure that a seller can create a
million stores to avoid bad reputation.
Proof of burn means that every
time a user opens a store,
they have to spend some
bitcoins that disappear or burn,
so it's really expensive
to make multiple stores.
The APP is also open source
so anyone can contribute,
but if they want to get a team of
people to continually maintain the apple
quality, unlike a lot of
other open source projects,
they should issue an internal
Tolkien eventually pretend.
The third example is scenario scenario.
He's a decentralized social networks.
This has been tried a few times before
and failed. I'm looking at you diaspora.
It always fails because the technology
was never there and it's been a security
nightmare to keep user data secure,
but I think scenario has a good shot
at making us valuable social networks.
It uses its own currency called the amp.
In traditional social networks
like Facebook and Twitter.
The middlemen gets all the money
for your data from advertisers,
but since there is no middleman,
since the APP is peer to peer,
if someone wants to pay
for your data or attention,
they'll pay you directly with amps.
All users get a reputation score based
on how many people like the content they
post. The higher the reputation,
the more valuable your content is.
The 10th and network is pure appear.
No one can shut it down like the Chinese
government did to Facebook and you own
your data. No one had Facebook can peer
into your private messages to friends.
Since your data is stored locally
instead of Fanta a service,
those are the few I could find
that I thought were pretty cool.
That's where the future
of software open source,
democratic and fair
compensation for all users.
There are more out there and many,
many more to be created in the future.
Check out the links in the description
below for more info and please subscribe
for more technology videos.
Thanks for watching.